So auf gehts, ok twitch hat noch nicht gecheckt dass es on ist, ist auch immer geil, jetzt
macht es.
Brauche ich das?
ist das das ppe-emote mit dem dem hut oder
ffz oder better twitch gb ich bin für ffz zumal beide beides animats können ich
finde aber die settings von ffz besser zumal die jetzt auch history chat history
haben seit ein paar versionen das heißt das einzige was ich von better twitch tv gebraucht
habe ist weg also können die jetzt auch 7 tv da bin ich noch bin ich noch ein
bisschen da können wir übrigens gleich schon video zu angucken warum ich das
nicht einschalte so mein hieß das 7 tv emotes genau das hat einen grund warum
ich das nicht einschalte logitech werbung ich habe kein logitech werbung
ich habe adblock an lull ne adblock geht ja auf twitch gar nicht mehr richtig habe ich
vergessen so ein wettrennen mit geht mal mal geht es nicht ja moin leute
morgen nice day for fischen ich habe nicht sonderlich gut geschlafen es war so
warm ich habe die klimaanlage zwar so eingestellt dass die immer ich kann nicht
pennen wenn die klimaanlage an ist ich weiß auch nicht es ist nicht die
lautstärke es ist nicht dass das status licht es ist ich weiß nicht es ist
glaube ich die luft die sich im raum bewegt wenn die klimaanlage an ist ich
kann dabei nicht pennen das heißt ich mache die klimaanlage dann
immer an ich habe die sich an besonderheit hat ja auch ein timer macht
die immer an lasse ich die zehn minuten laufen oder fünf bis zehn minuten bis
kühl ist dann mache ich wieder aus und versuche weiter zu pennen aber es klappt
also ist wirklich scheiße bei uns ging es heute nacht hat es gar nicht
großartig geregnet war nix
also es war wirklich viel zu warm zu machen gucken wir werden wir werden jetzt
normalerweise gucke ich mir nie das wetter an aber kucken wir mal wetter
haben wir denn da
heute ist bewölkt okay und es ist nicht mehr ganz so warm das ist auch schon mal
nice sehr nice nice die nächsten tage okay damit es wieder warm
okay also sprich morgen ist wieder komplett sonne ja morgen ist da wieder
kommt naja
ne also ich habe nichts mitbekommen das heißt kann ich so kann ich so schlimm
gewesen sein weil wenn es großartiges gewitter gibt da klappert immer mein
mein roll an wie verrückt und das war nicht der fall also vermute ich mal
da war nix
das ist ist das die logitech werbung die dich nervt zeigt mal ich will ich will
eigentlich kein logitech werbung zeigen weil ich nö ich mache jetzt kein sell
out für logitech care grade ich gucke mir nur mal die bewertung an okay die
bewertung sind schlecht to create the future must define the logic of was ist
denn das für eine unglaublich unlogische bescheuerte aussage die
logic of the past die funktioniert in der regel heute immer noch ganz gut also
es gibt so ein paar dinger die haben sich einfach etabliert zum beispiel links
und rechts gucken wenn man über die straße geht manche sachen sind echt
nicht verkehrt wenn man sie macht ja ist der neueste trend wir gucken nicht
mal wenn man die straße geht ok ok ok
sollte es so sollte es so so ist in recht leid sein oder wie warum sind die
dann alles so gangster aus was da fack war das grad ist sie gerade irgendwie als als als ich
ok war ich in einhorn was schöne autotune musik alles klar ok was was was möchten
die uns genau sagen ok ich glaube ich weiß was sie uns sagen wollen man soll
einfach jung jung stylish und hip sein und logitech kaufen damit man das ist
also im prinzip so was wollen die uns wahrscheinlich damit sagen vermute ich
jetzt mal immerhin hip und diverse können sie ja sein ich weiß jetzt
allerdings nicht inwieweit ich das mit logitech in verbindung bringe
werbung hat mit der realität oftmals ähnlich nicht so viel zu tun
die wisst ihr welche werbung mir extrem auf den keks geht in letzter zeit
manchmal wenn ich unten sitze und mittagessen es dann mache ich mache
ich auf dem tablet irgendwie ein bisschen radio also klassisch radio sende also
nicht klassische ex exquisite klassische musik ja sondern so noch so
klassische radio sende an meistens mit bisschen bisschen habe ich denn da
normalerweise rock land oder irgendwas irgendwas wo halbwegs ordentliche musik
läuft wo ich mich nicht selbst in die playlist kümmern muss so und da kommt
manchmal die werbung von glaub penny oder so ist das oder lidl und die sagen
dann jetzt corona schnelltests reduziert 80 cent das stück weil uns ihre
gesundheit am herzen liegt da denke ich immer ihr dumm schwätzer glaubt ihr
wirklich dass dass ich euch das abkaufe dass ihr das billiger macht weil euch
meine gesundheit am herzen liegt was für dumm schwätzer den geht's einfach
darum ihre kacktests noch zu verkaufen bevor die keiner mehr haben will den ist
meine gesundheit sowas von scheiß egal das ist ungefähr genauso wie wenn man
bei aliexpress bestellt und an die gesundheit von chinesen im container
angeblich interessiert wenn an das interessiert dann darf ich mal die
express bestellt oder besser gesagt das ist wie wenn aliexpress jetzt sagen
würde wir setzen uns für menschenrechte ein oder so das ergibt das ergibt irgendwie
widerspricht sich das alles so war der rewe fußball werbung jetzt nicht mehr
werbung als machte nicht kostenlos werbung für für die ganzen leden hier
nope no pass
also ich bin jetzt noch nicht in neun minuten elf sekunden und da geht noch
nicht so viel ab aber ex ex ich habe gehört semper semper video muss das ein
klassische musik aus dem intro rausnehmen weil das ist zwar abgelaufen
das copyright aber die aufnahme hatte noch copyright
richtig würde den ihre die gesundheit zum herzen liegen da würden sie das
eventuell kostenlos rausgeben oder zum einkaufspreis weitergeben ja
also im pool habe ich tatsächlich ich habe ja mittlerweile schon ein paar
luxusdinger zum beispiel in klo also ich nenne es mal luxus ja weil es nicht
viele haben ein klo der einen bobs abspült aber den pool habe ich noch
nicht und habe ich auch nicht vor pool braucht kostet geld braucht viel
pflege und arbeit und für die paar wochen in deutschland wo du das verwenden
kannst dann reicht mir die klimaanlage
feels bad man wird nicht angezeigt in ffz wenn ffz feels bad man nicht anzeigt
dann musst du
ich zeig dir was du machen musst
ich glaube das liegt daran weil ich den chat im fullscreen habe
ja dann gehst du hier zu addons und aktivierst betta twitch tv emotes und
dann siehst du auf feels bad man ich habe eine feste klimaanlage ich habe
eine mit so einem außengerät und im schlafzimmer und im arbeitszimmer so in
dann ja exquisite exquisite
wunderbar
das ist gewitter wie gesagt bei mir war glaube ich nix
habe ich irgendwelche questions übersehen was sind das eigentlich für huge cute cute emotes hier
ich habe nix übersehen so was genau
ich bin gestern oft gegangen nach dem stream und danach bin ich jetzt angegangen quasi da ohne viel aus ich habe geschlafen dazwischen ja ansonsten
keine ahnung was mit dem kabel ist
so was gucken wir uns denn heute mal an
das uns level cap das uns level cap gbaden
ich habe versucht zu schlafen oder ich ich habe voll ich war voll verwirrt heute nacht und zwar ich habe mir die klips angeguckt vom stream gestern ich gucke manchmal immer so danach was haben denn die leute dass wir teile klippen denn die leute immer so ich bin eigentlich im
Ich bin eingepennt zu den Clips von meinem eigenen Stream und irgendwie, ich weiß nicht
so genau wie das funktioniert, normalerweise gehen dann einfach unendlich Clips weiter.
Vielleicht bin ich vielleicht das Handy umgefallen auf meine Hand oder ich hab ehrlich gesagt
keine Ahnung.
Zumindest hab ich es irgendwie geschafft meinen eigenen Stream einzuschalten und ich hab dann
wohl gepennt und mein Stream von gestern lief die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund auf dem Handy
mit Lautsprecher und ihr glaubt euch nicht was für verwirrende Sachen da euer Hirn draus
macht wenn ihr euer eigenes Gelaber 2 Stunden lang nachts beim Pennen hört.
Da denkst du irgendwas stimmt hier nicht.
Du weißt nicht genau was, du hörst dich die ganze Zeit selbst aber du kannst dich eigentlich
gar nicht selbst hören weil du ja am Pennen bist und das ist ganz ganz ganz merkwürdig
kann ich euch sagen.
Bis ich es dann irgendwann gecheckt hab und ich sag hä was ist denn hier überhaupt los,
ah mein Stream läuft.
Von dem haben wir schon ein paar Videos geguckt ja.
Leider übertreibt er manchmal ein bisschen finde ich.
God Tier HTML Programming, ok das müssen wir uns angucken gleich.
Nicht einfach nur HTML Programmieren, nein Gott Tier und HTML sagen ja nur die Noobs,
die cool Leute sagen ja HTML.
Sag uns doch was für 5 fat Kanäle du auf YouTube abonniert hast, boah ich hab so viel Zeug
abonniert ich gucke mal, ich guck mal kurz, ok ich sag euch die ersten Kanäle die mein
Handy anzeigt.
Die die auf die erste Seite passen, also es geht nicht weil YouTube abgecrashed ist, mein
Handy bleibt dauerhaft, hallo mein Handy bleibt dauerhaft widescreen das soll das soll hoch
jetzt ist es hoch, ok jetzt also ich sag es euch was ist das erste, so ich geh jetzt mal
auf meine Subscriptions, so was ist das erste was ich vorgeschlagen kriege aktuell, Summoning
Soul kriege ich vorgeschlagen, ich geh mal auf all, so Summoning Soul kriege ich vorgeschlagen,
KiraTV kriege ich vorgeschlagen gerade an neuen Videos, Lazy Game Reviews kriege ich
vorgeschlagen, NDC Conferenz ist das irgendeine Konferenz Seite, dann kriege ich Epic NPC
Man vorgeschlagen, Bitluni kriege ich vorgeschlagen, Ben Eater kriege ich vorgeschlagen, Hookup
kriege ich vorgeschlagen, Krayt Scott kriege ich vorgeschlagen also an neuen Videos und
Microsoft Developer ist das letzte was es auf der ersten Seite noch gibt, so das war
jetzt meine erste Seite Subscriptions die mir jetzt vorgeschlagen werden, weil YouTube
sagt Most, auch eins hab ich noch vergessen Urknall Weltalluntersleben hat neues Video
das steht ganz oben hab ich gar nicht gesehen, Most Relevant sagt YouTube da geradezu, ich
scroll mal runter was am letztesten Relevant ist, ja gut das sind Channels die haben auch
schon ewig nichts hochgeladen, ok, das versteh ich, ja, wird heute Wishl Studio, das können
wir vielleicht heute Nachmittag machen, jetzt gucken wir uns erstmal mal Videos an und machen
auf am Mittag, Wishl Studio 2022 gibt's denn da jetzt schon ordentlich, hier Preview perfekt,
mal ganz davon abgesehen ich werd eh weiter Ryder verwenden, weil ich mir nicht vorstellen,
warum sieht die Seite so kacke aus, ich mir nicht vorstellen kann, dass sie irgendwie
da ran kommen, zumal dass sie auch nicht Cross Plus Form unter Linux ist und ich hab ehrlich
gesagt kein Bock wieder anzufangen unter Windows zu programmieren, ich bin da echt glücklich
mit, dass ich jetzt alles unter Linux programmieren kann was ich so mach, ja, ich kann Go unter
Linux programmieren, ich kann dort net unter Linux programmieren, mein Shellscripts eh,
und im Prinzip ist es mir so am liebsten wie es jetzt ist, sind jetzt 64 Spit, ja probier
mal aus später, jetzt nicht jetzt irgendwann Nachmittag oder so, mach ich vielleicht noch
mal streamen, aber ist die Windows, mal mit den Leuten gucken ob die Windows FM noch
da ist, da probieren wir das unter Windows 11 aus, Windows Wishl Studio 2020 unter Windows
11, das wäre noch mal in die Kombination schlechthin, gucken ob das läuft, Ryder unterstützt
kein Service Fabric, ja einige Cloud Implement, also einige Cloud Plugins, die gerade, gerade
haben die, in Wishl Studio Code gibt es ja für mehr oder weniger alles Plugins, ist
halt in Ryder ein bisschen doof, grad vor allem und Service Fabric ist ja irgendeine
Microsoft Geschichte, das ja, die Azure Functions Geschichte in Ryder ist auch nicht so geil,
also ich hat es ja letztens alles ausprobiert, wir haben ja im Stream nur Wishl Studio Code
und die Command Line verwendet, ich hab mir noch mal die, das Ryder Plugin angeguckt
und das Wishl Studio Plugin für Azure Functions, ich muss sagen, Wishl Studio war ok, aber
ultra alt backen hat nicht richtig funktioniert und Ryder hat auch, ich weiß gar nicht mehr
was, ich glaub die Plänen konnten es nicht richtig oder neu anlegen, irgendwas ging
hier auch nicht richtig, also die einzig sinnvollste Sache ist anscheinend Command Line
oder Wishl Studio Code, was sind das für agile Streamzeiten, das ist Hyper Agile alles
hier, diagonal skaliert, hyper konvergente Streamzeiten, das ist jetzt das neueste, da
stehen sie drauf, hyper konvergent Leute, das hab ich mir jetzt nicht ausgedacht, hyper
konvergente Infrastruktur, guckt euch das mal an, huge HCI, huge Buzzword, müsst ihr
euch merken, hyper konvergente Infrastruktur, ich hab ehrlich gesagt aus dem Stehgreif keine
Ahnung was es ist, ich glaub es geht darum, dass du deine Infrastruktur möglichst gut
auslastest mit verteilbaren Gedöns, aber ehrlich gesagt keine Ahnung, was ist hyper
konvergente Infrastruktur, ach was auch immer leckt mich, zu viel Buzzword Shit, kein Bock
jetzt drauf, Blockchain, ja muss, muss, muss, was macht eigentlich so, was macht eigentlich
gerade so der Bitcoin Kurs, oh, oh, oh, oh, das ist aber hart runtergegangen, Cacquait,
Alter, uiuiui, warum können die eigentlich keine gescheiten Crafts machen, der sackt
doch mal richtig, da ist ja der Google Craft besser, ok das ist doch ordentlich runtergegangen,
gucken wie viele immer noch hodeln, das ist das einzige Kryptowereport was ich mir gemerkt
hab, HODL, was macht denn, was macht dann Doguecoin, HODL, Alter, HODL, nein so schreibt
man das, HODL, das heißt HOLD, HOLD ON FOR DEAL, im Prinzip du verkaufst nie was, du behältst
es halt immer, Stiffers macht GameStop, lass mal kurz gucken, lass mal kurz gucken, also
wir gucken jetzt erstmal Doguecoin Kurs und dann GameStop, so die wichtigsten, die wichtigsten
Sachen, zeig mal her, aber krass, oder wie weit oben GameStop immer noch ist, ich mein
GameStop war weg, GameStop war einfach dead von einem Jahr oder so noch, was ich ja lustig
finde war, dass das wohl überhaupt gar nichts mit GameStop an sich zu tun hat, weil GameStop
an sich hat ja immer noch kein ordentliches Geschäftsmodell oder sagen wir immer noch
ihr auslaufendes Geschäftsmodell mit Offline-Spielen, das find ich geil, was macht Doguecoin, Doguecoin
ist auch wieder ein bisschen abgekackt, please wait, jetzt wird erstmal Javascript Bitcoin
meine angeschmissen im Hintergrund, naja, erstmal gucken, ob wir uns nicht irgendwie,
erstmal Prozess Explorer aufmachen, ob wir uns nicht auf so komischen Krypto-Mind-Dingern
irgendwie Drive-By-Troyana eingefangen haben, schauen wir mal, schauen wir mal was die CPU-Auslastung
sagt, ob da irgendwie die Massive Scamas Blockchain Action im Hintergrund am Start ist, ne sieht
nicht so aus, alles klar, gut, passt, so, Pog, mit was, mit was fangen wir dann an, God-HTML-Programming,
ok, damit fangen wir an, das ist nicht lang, das ist plus 49 Sekunden lang, also, zeig
mal her, der macht übrigens richtig gute Videos, also wenn es um Technik-Sachen geht,
den kann ich nur empfehlen zu abonnieren, so, God-HTML-Programming, also, warum, warum,
das haben wir in der Schule auch so gemacht, Leute, Hand hoch, wer das in der Schule auch
noch machen musste, so, auf dem Blog, jetzt unabhängig ob HTML oder irgendeine andere
Programmiersprache, wer hat in der Schule auch, also Schule oder Berufsschule ist egal,
oder in der Uni meinetwegen, ist egal, wer musste schon mal programmieren von Hand, weil
wir in Deutschland so fortschrittlich sind, ok, total viele, das ist echt unglaublich,
echt selten, das ist echt unglaublich.
Wir haben tatsächlich, in Programmieren in der Berufsschule haben wir, und auch in
Datenbanken in der Berufsschule, haben wir allen Ernst, das ist kein Spaß jetzt, wir
haben die, also wir haben, nicht Prüfung, wir haben die Arbeiten da halt, die, ja, wie
nennt man das, Arbeiten, Prüfung, keine Ahnung, also, immer so ganz normale Arbeit
schreibt halt mit Note, die haben wir zum größten Teil, gerade auch bei Datenbanken,
auf Papier geschrieben, es ist einfach so extrem hängen geblieben, es ist der Wahnsinn, und
es wurde dann auch nicht bewertet, ob du die Logik richtig gemacht hast, sondern du hast
dann wirklich Punkteabzug gekriegt, wenn du beispielsweise ein Semikolon in C vergessen
hast und sowas, also explizit nicht das, wie man eigentlich programmieren lernt, beziehungsweise
wofür man halt neben einem Editor hat oder irgendeine Compiler Warning oder so, es geht
ja eigentlich darum, dass man die Logik richtig gettet, ne, nicht, scheuer das ab, ihr wisst
wahrscheinlich, dass man die Logik richtig gettet, und nicht, dass man, nicht, dass man
ein Semikolon richtig macht auf Papier, das kenne ich, das ist tatsächlich nice, aber
ich muss ehrlich sagen, ich bin zu low brain für Emmet, und ich muss zu lange überlegen,
wie mein HTML aussehen soll, ich hab, ich bin nicht in der Lage, mein HTML mir im Kopf
soweit vorzustellen, dass ich Emmet sinnvoll verwenden kann, also wer Emmet nicht kennt,
er zeigt es, er zeigt es glaube ich auch gerade, das ist eine Möglichkeit, wie du HTML abkürzen
kannst, du schreibst dann keine Ahnung, drei mal diff, und dann macht er halt drei diffs
untereinander, aber da bin ich zu, da bin ich zu, zu three-head für Emmet, es ist quasi,
es ist quasi das Dark Souls der HTML Programmierung, um jetzt mal auch noch so einen weiteren ausgelutschten
Spruch zu bringen, ja genau, so in der Richtung, aber das Problem ist, das ist genau der Grund,
warum ich kein Emmet verwende, oder zu dumm dafür bin, ich weiß zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo
ich das hier schreibe, gar nicht, dass ich ein Navigationselement mit der Klasse cool
und der ID awesome habe, das weiß ich überhaupt nicht, da hab ich zu wenig Vorstellungskraft
frontendtechnisch für, ich würde das so machen, ich würde einen diff machen, erstmal den
Hintergrund rot, damit ich sehe, wo die Box ist, dann würde ich dem diff inline ein paar
Paddings und Margins passen, dass es an der richtigen Seite steht, inline style natürlich
alles, so und wenn das passt, dann geb ich ihm vielleicht ne Klasse und mach ne eigene
CSS Klasse, so advanced bin ich überhaupt nicht, was das angeht, ich krieg das nicht
mehr dazu lowbrane, du hast ne 6 bekommen, weil du zwei Semikolone, was sind die Mehrzahl
von Semikolons, Semikola, Semikolons, Semikolone, ich glaube Semikolone ist verkehrt, vergessen
hatte, weil er meint, die Software ist so nicht laufig auf dem Blatt, ok, das ist natürlich
Painschamp, das ist natürlich richtig, richtig Painschamp, also wenn man auf dem Blatt Papier
programmiert, sollte man über so Easy-Syntax-Fehler eigentlich wegsehen, weil dafür hat man ja
Compiler Warnings, einen ordentlichen Editor mit und sonst was, das ist bescheuert, solange
die Logik an sich richtig ist.
Ich frag mich übrigens immer noch, was die Mehrzahl von Nagios ist, auf dem Papier ist
es eh nicht, genau hättest du sagen müssen, auf dem Papier ist es doch eh nicht laufig,
ok, zeig mal her, ich geb dir Header, Alter, ich geb dir Header, Alter, ich geb dir Header,
Alter, mal坐 Chang, Anderson.
Das ist mir wirklich zu Big Brain, amit, ich hab doch gar keine Ahnung an dieser Stelle,
dass ich den Header will mit nem Artikel drin, mit ner unordert five Listelemente und dann
dass an der stelle denn überhaupt wissen dass ich das haben will
ich weiß das ist schon cool ja aber das ist mir zu alter ich sag ich sag gut ist ja gut
ich hab ne also damit bin ich noch nie warm geworden das liegt aber wahrscheinlich daran
weil ich nicht täglich frontend stels mache wenn ich täglich frontend kram machen würde
vielleicht wäre ich dann auch schon so advanced dass ich emmett verwenden würde
weil die die ganzen 360 klamor switch leute zufrieden stellen wollen moment es gibt jetzt
das final fantasy remake ist das jetzt raus ich dachte es gibt nur es ich dachte es gibt
nur season 1 oder sowas ja part 1 ist raus super super das wird doch nie fertig oder
das ist doch ein game was sind das kriegen die nie fertig die haben da jetzt irgendwie
acht jahre dran rum gemacht wollen jetzt noch mal acht jahre für teil 2 brauchen oder vielleicht
nicht dass das verstehe nicht ich weiß man darf nicht vergessen die haben das original
game in in in was drei jahren oder so gemacht und es war mehr oder weniger komplett neu
neue hardware neu ist alles und ich hab gelesen gta stellt jetzt die xbox 360 und ps3 server
ein und da ist mir bei der gelegenheit wieder mal eingefallen gta 5 gerade gta online ist
so alt dass es eine komplette generation generationen spand also also drei genne konsolen generationen
quasi jetzt schon hart oder also das ist uralt ups nein das wollte ich jetzt gerade anklicken
ok also was was gucken wir uns jetzt an look into self und trinken die besten mmos da muss
ich mich jetzt erstmal aufregen home automation ideen wir lassen uns jebane wir lassen uns
jebane von level cap ok level cap lassen uns jebane im prinzip stimmt ja eh immer nicht
aus dem titel drin steht hey guys level cap hier and today in gaming dice added more servers
für battlefield 4 ernsthaft waren das zu wie ja gut die bettel viel vier ist jetzt ja
auch kostenlos die leute jumpen ja da wie verrückt drauf oder leaked some big news sogar
bettel fiel drei war das gerade war das gerade allen wake habe ich das richtig gesehen es
allen wake wollen die wirkliche neues allen wake machen dass das wäre ja mal das wäre
richtig richtig porsche hier leaked some big news ea stance on loot boxes ich hoffe remedy
macht das wenn remedy das nicht macht wird das nix pressure and much more the height for
battlefield 2042 is spilling over to battlefield 4 players have been enduring massive server
queues for the game ever since 2042 was revealed the majority of battlefield 4 servers are maintained
by community members who pay to host custom servers these sudden influx of players quickly
overwhelm the community's generosity to alleviate the situation and sogar bettel viel drei servers
sind viel voller can get into matches quickly dice are increasing server capacity in the
u.s. west region that might leave some players in europe hunting for server slots but it
should be a significant improvement to q times for most other regions we're curious to hear if
you're going back to play battlefield for these days let us know if you have it tatsächlich
überlegt ob ich war eine runde bettel viel spieler spieler leaked an upcoming remaster of allen wake
and a pc release for final remaster remaster immer diese remaster scheiße die ganze zeit ich
mein allen wake ist jetzt schon in die jahre gekommen es ist jetzt vielleicht kein top super
shiny game mehr aber das ist das ist die durchaus ok aus immer noch das braucht doch kein immer
remaster das geht mir so auf den keks entweder ist es ein neuer serienteil oder es ist ein remaster
gespielt hat ist aber trotzdem mega geiles game leider fällt er mir könnte sagen der gameplay
aspekt ist ein bisschen an manch stelle fällt ein bisschen kurz aber die atmosphäre und story
ist echt eines der besten games die es gibt ist in games as placeholders for something else allen
wakes developer remedy is currently working with epic on two titles a triple a multiplatform game
and a smaller game set in the same universe it sounds like remedy might be working on an allen
wakes sequel and remastering the original problem ist das problem ist an einem allen wakes sequel das ende von allen wake war
so kryptisch und und man hat es nicht geblickt dass das mit einem sequel irgendwie schwierig wird
the process rumors have been buzzing often on for years that remedy were seeking funding for a sequel a couple of years ago die zwei jahre dann die lull dankeschön für den sub huge hypersubscription
so gerade mal hier in die in die sub box rein ich dass ich noch was vergessen habe ne passt bis
der erste heute 24 monate da reicht ja schon hypersubscription nicht mehr da bräuchte ich
eigentlich jetzt jetzt supreme hypersubscription oder sowas control ist anscheinend auch im selben
universum ja remedy remedy macht das gerne allen wake und wie ist das andere quantum break sind
ja auch mehr oder weniger im gleichen universum und ich glaube sogar max payne ist auch im gleichen also remedy
macht das gerne leider fand ich control control war das erste remedy game was ich nicht durchgespielt haben
wake from microsoft who were the original publisher since then remedy went to release quantum break and control
the latter was massive success for the developer partnering up with epic to finance allen wake
to seems like a smart move as for final fantasy 7 remastered sony's 12-month exclusivity agreement
for that game expired in april but square enix haven't announced a release date or
ah das ist das final fantasy remakes from the epic juck mich null we could be on the verge of some big announcements
the next gen update for metro exodus just launched for the playstation 5 and xbox consoles it offers
basically the same experience as the enhanced edition on allen wake 2 oder ich hoffe sie nennen
es nicht allen wake 2 sondern geben dem dinge im ordentlichen unterstellt da hätte ich auch bock drauf man hat
ja mit max payne 2 gesehen dass er remedy das prinzipiell kann aber sam lake muss das muss das
drehbuch dazu dazu machen sonst sonst also es muss muss von remedy sein und die leute müssen dass die
die gleichen story leute vom ersten müssen mit am start sein wird das nix minus some retracing features
on top of the visual upgrades the next gen upgrade also adds an fov slider improved fps
den fov slider in 2021 boar das erfolgt also massive bleeding edge poggers never never before innovation
lohnt sich das lohnt sich eigentlich das aktuelle das das letzte metro ich hab da sehr gemischte
sachen von gelesen will let you start the game from any point in the story achievements are
disabled if you use the chapter system to skip ahead though as for the quality of life upgrade
it's a dramatic improvement across the board if you own the game on console it's definitely
max payne hat in 20 in sechs wochen zwanzigjähriges da fällt mir mal wieder auf wie alt ich bin ich
habe das zum release gespielt ist edition running on pc so check out that video if you want an idea
of what it offers ea has folded under pressure to be more transparent about fifa's ultimate team packs
players can now preview what each pack contains before buying it these previews have a timer that
prevents you from previewing multiple packs of the same kind until it expires while the timers active
you can be is it's immer noch ein absolutes rätsel warum das leute machen in the pack or not
ich verstehe es nicht and saying that this changes a big deal would be a massive understatement
ea have been brought to court in multiple countries because of fifa's loop packs violating anti gambling
laws it's unclear if the new pack preview system will be enough to please the countries that took
ea to court moment ich brauche ich brauche neues emote mir ist gerade einfach ich brauche pains
champing nee wie heißt das wie heißt das die mode wo er so den kopf schüttelt es ist weird
champing ups weird champing genau das brauche ich das ist nämlich genau das richtige für sowas
und okelhaus im outboard wird champing ok perfekt soll jetzt das ganze noch mal please
understatement ea have been brought to court in multiple countries because of fifa's loop
pack weird champing funktioniert nicht ups ups falsch falsches ebauchloch das gift ist
einfach nur lahm as fuck weil es nicht transparent ist das gift ist mega langsam das leht überhaupt
nicht richtig ich meine es funktioniert immerhin violating anti gambling laws it's unclear if the new pack preview system will be enough to please the countries that took ea
to court but it's a step in the right direction today call of duty news is just a quick update about yesterday's launch of course in season 4 the update made several big balance changes that have upended the game's meta but it also introduced a new armored truck in standard matches unfortunately an invisibility exploit related to invisibility exploit so geil ich sag noch es ist bestimmt wieder verbugt invisibility exploit also rave
und soft ist echt der unfaekste haufe den ich kenne in standard matches unfortunately an invisibility exploit related to the armor truck quickly started making the rounds rave and have removed the truck from the game to work on a fix this isn't the first time a vehicle related invisibility exploit was added in a war zone update the game so unfaek
die xbox design lab is open for business again microsoft shut it down during the xbox series x launch to make it meet demand for controllers the service let users customize the color of all the parts of either the xbox one or xbox series controller and a fully customized controller including engraving will run you about seventy dollars that's below average for similar services from third party
unfortunately the xbox elite controller isn't available on the design lab outriders developers making some significant changes to the game's grand resident sleeper residents update level brackets that prevented certain qualities of loot from dropping are being removed as well but base scaling still applies so don't expect to start getting weapons way beyond your current level the update also adds an anti duplication system that rerolls duplicate items once in general
this game was also only successful because it came out at a time of absolute laziness and the people wanted a bit of destiny style grind i don't even know if it still has any players or how many players it still has
that's unfortunate to see a game that supports solo play not allowing online play as well
the managing director of ubisoft massive david pulfeld is stepping down and taking a six month break he's stepping down at a pretty crucial time for the studio they're currently knee deep in development of an avatar game a star wars title and mania
avatar spiel im jahr 2021 von wann ist der film 2005 oder so das ist warum warum denn jetzt
containing the division to the avatar game was just revealed during e3 and the star wars title will be the first disney era title in the franchise avatar 2 auch noch avatar ist echt ein film der hat keine der hat keine fortsetzung gebraucht ich meine das erste war schon dort meine meine also deutlich zu lang und irgendwie auch nicht durchgängig irgendwie engaging ja vor allem der abschluss war auch in ordnung warum brauchen wir dann ok man braucht einen zweiten teil wegen stonks ganz klar
developed by ea a lot is riding on the success of these games pulfeld said in his statement announcing his change of position that he had achieved everything i had once dreamed up he's been with the studio for 17 years and his replacement as managing director has already been selected and he'll take on a new role at the company when he returns from a six month break co-op adventure title it takes two that's all richtig gut sein das soll richtig gut sein
that's a massive achievement for its studio hazel light their previous game wenn man freunde hat natürlich nur hit 3.5 million units sold this past january but it launched back in 2018 is on track to surpass a way out sales in a matter of months before we get to our final story today i just wanted to say happy friday we'll have a recap of this week's top stories for you tomorrow be sure to tune in for any story or coverage you might have missed if you think we should revisit any stories in particular for the past week
let us know in the comments nintendo switch users have been reporting well if i want to have a recap then i can just watch the video again
nintendo online
nintendo online in kombination ist immer ein desaster für massives weirdchamping
nix
jedes mal wenn nintendo online was verkackt was trinken oder bist aber ganz schön schnell besoffen wobei es ist ja nicht so gehäuft es ist es ist konstant aber nicht immer alles auf einmal die verkacken es ja die ganze zeit über
major reveals wtf deck und was gibt es denn auf egal level cap muss gucken woran bleibt was läuft auf deinem server hypervisor mit welchen vms auf einem server da läuft kvm mit einer vm der reste im container die eine vm ist mein home assistant als vm weil der nicht richtig im als container setup funktioniert
der rest ist alles container stells
windows 11 league erste eindruck uns installation ich frage mich wie man aus diesem mini league wenn wir haben es uns im stream angeguckt ne windows 11 wie kann man daraus was kann man da groß draus machen es gab ja nix es gibt ja ich meine ich habe die vm noch auf
nach jeder guck da ist die vm es gab ja nix das einzig nennenswerte was es gab ist dass es startmenu das ist das startmenu in der mitte ist und aussieht wie gnome 3 ansonsten gab es nix das ist es ist genauso inkonsistent hässlich
noch runde ecken runde ecken sorry runde ecken habe ich vergessen es ist genauso inkonsistent hässlich wie windows 10 es hat immer noch den gleichen müll dabei wie windows 10 also das alte control panel und sonst was also weiß nicht wie man da überhaupt es sieht aus wie windows 10x im endeffekt was sie da mal vorgestellt haben bloß zusammengemerched mit windows 10
ich glaube apple hat keine rechte auf runde ecken ich meine apple denkt bestimmt dass sie auch vieles rechte haben aber ich glaube wenn es hart auf hart kommt ja es hat halt mindestens 10 verschiedene designs ja ja ist so warte mal ich gucke mir das bild mal an ja es ist so
ja das ist ein gutes beispiel das ist wirklich ein gutes beispiel hier hast du windows 95 sound settings die ja by the way immer noch genauso ausschauen hier also es hat ja alles aus windows 11 wahrscheinlich windows 95 windows nt das wusste ich gar nicht dass der device manager damals ein bisschen anders aus aber im prinzip immer noch so
windows xp das ist eindeutig windows xp geschichten genau dann haben wir windows store 2015 dass ich genau hässliche game bar ja bei den amis ist es ja so du kannst auf alles patente haben die werden ja nicht geprüft also nicht so nicht so hart geprüft die amis machen eher die taktik wir nehmen einfach patente an für alles und dann sollen die leute sich verklagen um zu gucken was stimmt
so das ist vista jawoll genau warum moment warum hat der control panel als vista und als xp
das ist in das ist wenn man in das control panel reinklicken das ist die control panel übersicht ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja ja
ja auf youtube jetzt also wir haben pett und was haben wir sonst noch hab jetzt als emot auf twitch das heißt wenn du emotes lots brauchst du kannst aus
Du kannst Wuppet aus FFZ oder Bellatwitch-TV, wo du das hast, rausmachen, da hast du wieder E-Mode-Slots.
Hab ich gesagt YouTube? Lull. Ja, ihr wisst, dass das manchmal nicht mal so gut funktioniert.
Aber nur Wuppet, weil das andere hatten wir nicht drin. Das andere war ja noch nirgendswo.
Alter, was ist das hier eigentlich für ein... Ach, das ist hier Press of the Wild-Soundtrack, oder?
Ja. Weitere Grund, warum ich ehrlich gesagt den Press of the Wild-Soundtrack nicht sonderlich geil fand.
Ich fand den Skyward Sword-Soundtrack viel geiler. Spiel kann man sich jetzt drüber streiten.
Ich persönlich fand's echt nice. Es gibt viele, die finden Skyward Sword das Schlechteste überhaupt.
Aber ein bisschen epischer Soundtrack, so wie der Trailer-Soundtrack zum Beispiel, hätte Press of the Wild schon nicht geschadet.
Find ich.
So, dann hast du Paint mit Ribbon-Bars, was ja nicht mal... Paint wird dann nicht mal weiterentwickelt.
Paint ist quasi ausge... Painted. Ausgemalt. Ausge... Paintchamped.
So, dann haben wir Windows 11 Native Look. Genau, das ist das, was ein bisschen aussieht wie Chrome 3.
Wie fandest du den Minch Cap-Soundtrack? Kann ich mich nicht mehr richtig dran erinnern, aber wahrscheinlich ganz gut.
Windows 10 RTM Modern, das ist dieses Setting-Geschiss. Genau. Und das ist Fluent.
Es ist... Und das ist der Windows... Das ist Windows... Es ist so pale einfach.
Nur das ist... Windows wirkt so wie... So krass zusammengestöckelt, das Stück Soft... Also richtig zusammengewürstet, dass...
Ähm... Die Sache ist nur die, das ergibt sogar Sinn.
Zumindest früher bei Microsoft war es ja so, dass Windows nicht ein Team war, was sich um Windows gekümmert hat.
Das ist ja auch klar. Ich meine, das ist ja auch ziemlich groß.
Sondern, dass ganz viele Teams quasi so fast schon rivalisierend sich um Teile von Windows gekümmert haben.
Angeblich kam deswegen auch überhaupt erst zu diesem WinRT JavaScript-Unfall unter Windows 8, falls ich an den jemanden noch erinnern kann.
Die haben ja gesagt, ab Windows 8 haben sie gesagt, man macht Windows-Anwendungen jetzt mit C++ oder JavaScript.
Das ist ja... Hat es ja nicht lange gehalten, zum Glück.
Ich finde es so immer geil, wie die denken, dass die Leute mitmachen.
Der Witz ist ja bei Windows-Anwendungen, die Leute machen mittlerweile gar nicht mehr mit.
Die Leute verwenden mittlerweile einfach für alles einen Browser und machen ihre Anwendung da rein.
Einfach weil keiner Bock drauf hat, sich mit dem Microsoft-Shit zu beschäftigen.
Die nehmen einfach jetzt irgendeinen Elektron und gut ist.
Okay, ja, aber so viel zu Windows.
So, was haben wir denn hier sonst noch so schönes?
Also, YouTube möchte unbedingt, dass ich dieses Video gucke, aber ich weiß nicht, ob ich das gucken will.
Aber YouTube ist der Meinung, das musst du gucken. Guckt euch das an hier. Bam, da ist es wieder.
Zack, und das sollte ich mir auch angucken. Refresh.
Bam, schon wieder am St... Ach nee, doch.
Da ist es wieder.
Das ist ganz scharf drauf.
Blazer ist auch so eine Microsoft-Geschichte, die lässt mich irgendwie kalt.
Ich sehe da den großen Sinn noch nicht drin.
So cool es ist, Frontend-Sachen in C-Sharp zu programmieren, anstatt in Javascript.
So genau den großartigen Vorteil sehe ich da jetzt nur nicht von.
Okay, also was gucken wir uns als nächstes an?
Genau, wenn wir gerade bei Twitch sind, gucken wir uns das Video an.
Weil, das wollte ich euch zeigen. Weil gestern haben ein paar Leute gefragt, warum wir das nicht machen.
Und das ist der Grund, warum ich 7TV nicht aktiviere. Also kommt in dem Video vor.
Übrigens, das beste Video von dem, was ihr euch unbedingt angucken müsst, wenn ihr Twitch guckt.
KekW vs. LulW.
Das hier. Das ist das beste Twitch-Meme-Emote-Video aller Zeiten.
Das gucken wir uns jetzt nicht an, aber wer es noch nicht gesehen hat, muss das sehen. Das ist das beste.
Das gucken wir aber nicht. Das ist das beste. Das ist wirklich das beste.
Okay.
.app. Ich brauche auch unbedingt eine.app-Domain.
Leute, warum habe ich eigentlich speedchamp.org gemacht? Warum habe ich nicht speedchamp.app gemacht? Sekunde.
Wir gucken jetzt bei irgendeinem, oder? Ich will eine.app. Ich will eine.app-Registern.
speedchamp.app
Beast-Mode
schon gekauft. speed.champ. Das wäre natürlich cool. Nee, ist mir zu teuer. Kaufe ich nicht.
.app ist secure namespace. If you want to build a website using this, you will need an SS. Hä?
Hä? Was hatten die Domain mit meinem SSL-Zertifikat zu tun? Das eine hat doch mit dem anderen absolut gar nichts zu tun.
Nee, die kaufe ich mir nicht. Die kaufe ich mir nicht. 12 Euro im Jahr ist mir zu teuer.
.org kostet 4,50 Euro oder so im Jahr. Das sehe ich überhaupt nicht ein.
speedchamp.ai hat zwar mit.ai nichts zu tun, aber schadet ja nichts. Kostet 58 Euro. Nee.
X, Y, Z. Das ist gut. 84 Euro im Jahr. Perfekt. Nee, Moment.
Nee, was ist das da unten drunter?
Wie läuft's? Verfolgt irgendjemand noch was?
Wie läuft's bei dem auf YouTube denn so? Ich habe nicht ein Stream geschaut auf YouTube, ehrlich gesagt.
Ah, das als Sub-Emote, das habe ich doch schon drin. Rage-Ding. Hab ich das nicht schon drin?
Okay, es hat keiner eine Ahnung. Alles klar. Anscheinend.
Anscheinend. Haben wir doch. Anscheinend. Moment, das muss ich jetzt mal gucken.
YouTube. Anscheinend gucken das immer noch viel, oder? Ja, ja.
Okay, das gucken immer noch saumäßig viele. Alles klar. Gut, nice.
Ja gut, das machen die jetzt am Anfang. Sobald das verbreitet ist, kommen sie auch um die Ecke und sagen, wir brauchen für die Infrastruktur 5 Euro im Monat, was auch okay ist.
Da sage ich gar nichts dagegen.
Lofo ist Deinsch für den Sub, HugeSub14.
Ja, das ist Fail. Ganz ehrlich, ich habe kein Bock, nur Emotes in Chatterino verwenden zu können.
Bane's Champ.
Wie von Sulu ist auch dabei.
Dass sie das nicht genommen haben auf Twitch, verstehe ich bis heute nicht.
Ja, das verstehe ich nicht, warum die es nicht genommen haben.
Erst mal das beste Emote ist schon mal drin. Ohne Nun wie geht nichts.
Schöner JavaScript Fehler. Jetzt kommt das, warum ich 7TV nicht aktiviere.
Nein, gleich kommt es, warum ich das nicht aktiviere.
Stimmt, gibt es nicht mehr.
Was hat der Chailor geschrieben, jetzt ist er weg.
Jetzt kommt, warum ich das nicht aktiviere.